[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاوديه عباره عن منابع او مجامع وجميع
الاوديه لدينا عباره عن مجامع لمياه
الامطار فهي احواض تجمع مياه الامطار
الساقطه عليها والامطار في قسم الى قسمين
امطار محليه تكون في بقعه دون ثانيه وهذه
هي التي تمشي ثعبان والشعبان اصغر من
الاوديه وامطار عامه وهي التي تشمل عددا
من المناطق وهي التي تمشي الاوديه وعندنا
عدد من الاوديه عالميه وطويله وعظيمه وادي
الرمه وادي حنيفه ابن نجد وادي رميه وادي
العقيق وادي فاطمه هذا بالحجاز وادي سرحان
بالجوف وادي حلي ووادي جازان وادي عرعر
والاوديه مصدر رئيس من مصادر المياه
الصحيه لنمو الاشجار البريه الطلح والسدر
والغضاء والرمث الا ليت شعري هالابيتن
ليله بجنب الغضا اسجي القلاص النواجي فليت
الغضا لم يقطع الركب عرضه وليس الغضا ما
شركادا لياليا
[موسيقى]